So if you're not following Jessica Valenci and abortion everyday
here on TikTok and Instagram,
you definitely should be. Yesterday
I Learned from the Abortion Everyday Instagram page
about the Georgia abortion ban being repealed.
A Georgia judge has struck down the state's six week abortion ban,
and Judge Robert Mcberney's comments on the ruling
were what really stood out to me.
Specifically this quote that was pulled on the abortion everyday page
it is not for a legislator,
a judge, or commander from The Handmaid's Tale
to tell these women what to do with their bodies
during this period when the fetus cannot survive outside the womb
anymore so than society could or should
force them to serve as a human tissue bank
or to give up a kidney for the benefit of another.
And these last few lines in particular, comparing, um,
forcing women to carry a fetus to term with forced organ donation
is something that reminded me of a piece
that I read in an ethics class,
a piece by Judith Jarvis Thompson called A Defensive Abortion
that I read in, like,
Ethics 1:01 when I was a freshman in 2016.
This piece essentially grants,
for the sake of argument, that the fetus has a right to life,
but Thompson uses thought experiments to argue that the right to life
does not include, entail,
or imply the right to use someone else's body to survive,
and that induced abortion is therefore morally permissible.
A little clip From the Wikipedia page about the article.
You wake up in the morning
and find yourself back to back in bed with an unconscious violinist.
A famous unconscious violinist.
He's been found to have a fatal kidney ailment.
And the society of Music Lovers
has canvassed all the available medical records
and found that you alone have the right blood type to help.
They have therefore kidnapped you.
And last night, the violinist circulatory system was plugged into yours
so that your kidneys can be used to extract poisons from his blood
as well as your own. If he has unplugged from you now,
he will die, but in nine months,
he will have recovered from his ailment
and can be safely unplugged from you.
And obviously, most pro abortion people are of the opinion
that if a person wants an abortion,
they should be able to get one,
no questions asked.
But if you want or need to get philosophical with it,
for someone who is kind of challenged by the,
I don't know, moral justification of abortion,
we can talk about why we expect women
to be willing to carry a fetus to term for 40 weeks.
We wouldn't expect a person to be kidnapped
and hooked up to another person for nine months to keep them alive.